there is so much news out of Comic-Con
but let's be honest all eyes were on
what would the Black Panther sequel look
like without leading manchad with
Bozeman yes and this is the first time
the cast is back on the stage without
Chadwick but rest assured fans are
feeling the love for wakanda forever
to see the fruits of our labor out there
it's very very moving and just brings us
to tears my entire family
first time we saw the trailer for me I
had a lot of emotions
it's a great alignment of souls the two
minute and 12 second trailer was
revealed after a live performance by
Senegalese singer Baba Mall
you guys are going to be the first
audience to see
the trailer for Black Panther what kind
of fabric the crowd's reaction chills
cheers and just wow there's action and
epic war between wakanda and Atlantis
and an emotional tribute to the late
actor Chadwick Boseman who died from
colon cancer in 2020. there was a big
hug on stage it was extremely emotional
I feel like Chadwick is pulsing through
these people the last time we were all
together on that stage Chad was with us
it's a very important thing that will
kind of forever not only brings the same
level of joy and inspiration that the
first black panther film did but it also
is a tribute to what he did and what she
had brought to the not just the us but
to the world
black panther wakanda forever opens on
November 11th the debut was bittersweet
for director Ryan coogler who talked
about watching the original black
panther trailer with Chadwick at
Comic-Con five years ago are you just
squeezing down on my shoulder the whole
time and when it went off he was like oh
man it was amazing congratulations and I
couldn't even lift my arm you know I
promise you I could feel his hand on you
right now
[Applause]
into the teaser we see a another Panther
being released a panther claw how does
the franchise move forward honoring
Chadwick of course but without him what
can you tell me about moving forward we
do it with love and care and style and
style also doing it with style how are
you sir tonight entertainment
tonight we have Chris Pratt is Star-Lord
Peter Quill Chris and his Guardians crew
partied backstage before making their
Hall age appearance but it was
bittersweet for Chris Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 dropping May next year is
the final movie in the lineup and caps
off Chris's eight years in the Marvel
Universe you watch the Multiverse with
with your son what does it mean to you
to leave it for your kids I remember at
the end of uh at the end of Guardians on
my last day I gave a little
speech to our our crew and our cast as
we were rapping out and I said like the
extraordinary thing is our name is on
this thing and it will be alive longer
than we will it's been a really fun and
that's why you're seeing people be
emotional because it's like
too almost too good to be true like it's
over it's sad you know it's just sad
star-lord's little buddy Ant-Man AKA
Paul Rudd has Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania due out in February Paul
told us Comic-Con is just like being in
high school you kind of feel like you're
a part of the club it's a little bit
like a class reunion and uh we can't
help but get caught up in the excitement
that's even like the audience feels in
Paul H
you have been warned the DC universe
will never be the same again yeah that's
a very buff Black Adam Dwayne The Rock
Johnson fulfilling his 20-year dream of
bringing a superhero to Comic-Con it was
a moment Heroes don't kill me
well I do the best thing about the
costume wound up being
um removing all the muscle pads I put it
on and it had all the muscle padding in
it you put muscle padding over muscle
well then your muscle goes away and I
was like well this is ridiculous I've
worked too hard I've worked my butt off
for this so we removed the muscle
padding out of the costume so now it's
like just a latex fit on me of course I
had to ask the rock about his tortilla
challenge with Buddy Kevin Hart I carry
tortillas with me everywhere I go
in case somebody wants some smoke no
tortilla smoke all right I've been hard
that was a dream come true for him by
the way
Zachary Levi brought his own speaker to
the red carpet and led the cast of
Shazam Fury of the Gods including New
Edition Lucy Liu in an all-out photo
shoot
you always got to bring the Vibes man
Zach has the best playlist all of it
from the 80s yeah and he's just he
brings a brightness and an energy to the
set that is infectious the sequel drops
December 21st and has Shazam learning to
cope with his superhero status something
Zach told us he's had to do in real life
I feel like a fraud you've been recently
speaking about mental health issues and
I feel like it's such an important topic
just at this time coming out of the
pandemic why is that so important to you
back in 2017 right before I booked this
job I had a full-on mental breakdown I
didn't realize that my whole life I had
been struggling with clinical depression
at various times struggling with anxiety
probably my entire life until I had this
total breakdown and I went to this
life-changing life-saving therapy ever
every bad thing that goes on in this
world we can ultimately I think we can
correct out those courses if we go and
just heal people heal their minds heal
their hearts I can't stop talking about
that
Cameron Diaz is coming back to the world
of acting what are the chances we get
you Cameron and Drew on another movie
together at some point I don't know I
mean those are some very busy ladies I
didn't even know she was out of the
business so she's never in my heart
she's always right here
I mean I would be happy to have the
three of them in any content you know
I'll be the fourth I know Charlie's
Angels are three but throw me in there
first yes get our girl in there you see
my pitch back listen also I'd be remiss
if I didn't mention that the internet's
boyfriend Keanu Reeves was also there
yes our boyfriend our boyfriend and he
gave the world a first look at John Wick
chapter four that's out next march
[Music]